got a special treat for you today if you
are wanting to absolutely crush it this
year in property investing now the thing
is your property is this okay if you
want to get into property there's so
many
strategies out there there's
biorefurbish refinance lease option
agreements deal packaging rent to rent
deal sourcing service accommodation
there's so much you could potentially do
hmos what do you do where do you get
started buy to let what do you do so
here's the thing there's no one right or
wrong answer I can stand here all day
and teach you about different strategies
and you could be like a kid in a candy
shop so I'm gonna try this I'm gonna try
this I'm gonna try this but I want you
to really work out what is the right
strategy for you in 2023 so because of
that
I recently published a book okay this is
on Amazon and this is not a book about
one particular strategy not a book
that's even about me this
is where I've selected 30 of my students
all doing different stuff from different
backgrounds like we got um people like
Naomi here Nanny when I met Naomi she
was already a multi-millionaire and I've
helped her diversify into property into
into building a property portfolio but
then you've got other people like Amelia
who worked for me she was my
videographer and then wanted to get into
property Darcy Darcy dropped out of
University with nothing she dropped out
of uni with no job as a teenager and
she'd started a rent to service
accommodation business we've got people
like uh Lewis okay Lewis Dawson Lewis
has built up a massive deal sourcing
company so here's the thing every
chapter
in this book there's 30 chapters has got
30 stories
and every story is different different
people different backgrounds different
strategies different lessons and I think
it's really important for for you that
you read different stories because
there's going to be some that you can
really relate to you might think oh my
gosh yes I can relate to um I can relate
to these guys because they Lee and Joe
because they have done least optional
agreements but use the buy refurbish
refinance strategy they're living in
Portugal they've built up a really deep
portfolio or it might be that you can
relate to
um to this guy okay there's a guy called
Simon here he is Simon Olsen who is is
buying houses on the beach
renting them out of service
accommodation and pulling out recycling
all his money there's Jeremy Jeremy
Grigg okay Jeremy and Jenny they're
using other people's money to recycle
their portfolio there's people doing
deal sourcing rent to rent
um Aiden Aiden got made redundant and
built up so there's a real mixture of um
different strategies in here so I really
want you to get a copy of this in your
hands here's how badly I want you to
read this book I've made it I've made
I've done a deal with Amazon
and right now you can get this from
Amazon you can download the Kindle
version of this book right now for free
all right no charge however this is a
limited time I think Amazon only allowed
me to do it for like about three days I
think it is so if you're watching this
now and if this video has only gone live
the last few days I'm Gonna Leave a link
below where you can download it you can
buy a copy if you want I think this
costs around about 10 pounds if you want
to get the um the paperback copy in your
hands download it for free read the
stories because I want you to be
inspired I want you to be enlightened I
want you to learn the ABC of property
okay I want you to stop getting deals
and um you know it's all good you're
hearing from me every week about what
I've done about the developments I'm
doing but when you you read these
stories man real people and if anyone in
your family is skeptical right oh
property investing doesn't work
get the paperback version and put it in
their house and say tell me tell me it
doesn't work and they might go oh well
there's only 30 you know 30 people well
no there's not only 30. what about my
what about this volume one volume two
this is volume three
so there's 30 that's 90 90 case studies
winners on a Wednesday every week I've
been doing windows on a Wednesday for
four years this is possible but now's
your turn now's your turn so I want to
see you in volume four this is volume
three I want to see you in volume four
and to get in volume four first thing
you need to do is read volume three read
it become familiar with the strategies
follow in their footsteps okay and go do
the same thing I think the best way to
achieve something is to find other
people that have achieved it first
that's the best way so these people have
achieved it first go follow it it's free
you can get the Kindle version right now
on Amazon for free download it now it's
on your
um Kindle or your iPhone or your
computer wherever you hold it forever
okay for free all I'm asking in exchange
is I would really love it if once you've
downloaded it once you've had a ridge
throw please kindly do leave a review
okay leave me an Amazon review of the
book enjoy it go kick some ass and I
hope to meet you soon I'm Gonna Leave a
link in the description enjoy peace
foreign